Hello, everyone. Welcome to the Lang focus channel. And my name is Paul.
Today. We're going to talk about African American vernacular English
African-American vernacular English,
which you may also hear referred to as Ebonics is a group of dialects of English
that developed among African-American communities in the United States because
of the expressive and innovative nature of these dialects.
They are very influential and they are the source of many slang,
expressions and idioms that are used in general, American English,
and even international English yet,
despite the fact that English speakers borrowed their favorite pieces of AAV E
there's still the persistent belief that it speakers speak bad English or broken
English as though they're constantly making mistakes when they speak.
But any linguists will tell you, that's not how language works.
AAV E is not broken standard English. It's simply not standard English.
It's something else.
Enslaved African people were first brought to what is now the United States in
16, 19, and over the next two centuries,
hundreds of thousands more were brought over similar to the development of
English based Creole languages and the Caribbean AAV.
He developed from contact between speakers of West African languages and their
English speaking, slave masters,
as well as indentured servants from great Britain and Ireland. But while AAV,
he has some Creole like features it's much closer to standard English than
Caribbean Creoles are.
One theory suggests that it arose as a result of the slaves learning the
dialectal English spoken by the indentured servants who were poor and oftentimes
not proficient in standard English.
Another theory suggests that it developed as a Creole language,
but then converged with standard English through a process of decriminalization.
The more accepted theory is the first one,
but there was probably also some Creole influence from the slaves brought to the
U S from the Caribbean with black Americans living as a largely separate
community. First under slavery. Then under segregation,
it makes sense that they would develop their own enduring dialects.
And it also makes sense that they would develop their own in-group expressions
and idioms that were difficult for hostile outsiders to understand the great
northward migration of the 20th century helped establish AEE as an enduring
dialect group throughout the country. First off,
let me be clear that not all African-Americans speak a V E and there are some
people who do speak it,
who aren't African-American and as is typically the case with non-standard
varieties of a language AAV E exists on a continuum with standard English and
people mix the two of them to varying degrees, depending on the situation,
their socioeconomic status and their perception of the dialect.
And it's also true that there's variation within AAV II based on region and
generation,
but I'll describe some typical features that are unquestionably a part of Ave.
People often associate AAV with its slang,
especially words and expressions that have crossed over into other varieties of
English, often through music and other media words like dis,
which is short for disrespect, beef, meaning a conflict squash,
meaning to put an end to something co-sign meaning to vouch for someone,
give props,
meaning to give praise or recognition to someone and lots of other expressions
like that.
But this kind of slang is not representative of AAV E slang by its very nature
is always changing. The vast,
vast majority of vocabulary is standard English vocabulary,
even though sometimes words are used slightly differently,
either in form or in meaning.
The core of AAV is really it's grammar at its phonology.
Let's examine its grammar verbs.
There are a lot of little differences in how verbs are used first is and are are
often left out. She overdosed that's before a phrase showing location.
He will funny do that's before announced phrase.
There you go on the craze here it's left out before an adjective.
They're also left out before the present progressive ING.
He don't know what he talking about. Note that.
Isn't are the only forms have to be that are dropped.
Amma's not left out and need there all the past tense forms wasn't were more on
those later or B also isn't are,
can't be dropped at the end of a sentence. Know what it is.
The basic rule is that they can only be dropped in AAV II in the same contexts
in which they can become contractions in standard English,
habitual B.
There are contexts in which speakers of AAV used be when is, or are,
would be used in standard English. For example.
We'd be working 24 seven.
B has a special purpose. When used like this, it indicates habitual action.
This sentence is also possible. We work, but that just means working right now,
rather than habitually working over an extended period of time. Another example.
He always be telling people what to do.
So you can see that the use of B is not a random choice or mistake.
It's systematic and it's grammatically correct.
According to the rules of AAV E there's also an intensive habitual marker.
This is similar to habitual B, but it's more emphatic.
He's they running late for work.
This means that it happens pretty much all the time. It's habitual.
There's also an intensified continuous marker steady.
It shows that the action is in progress,
but not necessarily habitual over a longer period of time.
You never listen. I've been told you to stop, but you steady plan.
Playing here.
I would probably say playing around or messing around lack of
person number agreement before we saw this sentence.
He don't know what he talking about. This part,
he don't may have stood out to you as different verb.
Conjugations are generally flattened so that they are the same regardless of
person and number.
They was acting crazy. They.
Was rather than they were in the present tense.
This usually means that the third person singular form doesn't have an S.
Yeah, you work at the shop down the street.
He work rather than he works. That's the basic pattern. Most of the time,
a common expression that seems to contradict this rule is God's to.
Okay. You Trevor, I got to go.
Plus the S on gods, even when it's not in the third person,
singular God's too seems to have developed as distinct from Ghada,
both being contractions of how it got to God.
Stir is more emphatic than goddaughter, complete,
active or perfective done. The word done is frequently used as an aspect marker,
showing that an action has been completed.
You know, you don't miss stuff, right?
This is often interpreted as referring to an action completed in the very recent
past, but that's not necessarily the case. It could be further back in the past,
but using done gives the feeling that the situation after the action is
different than the situation before it.
You know, woke up the whole neighborhood.
The word being is also used with verbs in two ways.
One way is called unstressed bean. It's used, like have been,
or has been in standard English.
She'd been married for a long time.
Also stressed being when been pronounced, more like bin is stressed.
It means that the action occurred a long time ago or that the action or state
has been continuing for a long time. She been married.
This means that she's been married for a long time.
The stress on been indicates that the marriage began in the remote past.
So the phrase for a long time is unnecessary. In fact,
when using stress to in it's actually ungrammatical to include an adverbial
phrase like that.
Ben finished my homework.
There are a few special ways to express the future in AAV.
One way is using Goan or gona, which is a contraction of going to.
We go visit them. So go now.
Is used in casual speech and a lot of varieties of English.
So this is no big surprise.
Another more distinctive future form is finna I'm finna go home.
This is a contraction of fixing too,
which is frequently heard in dialects of the Southern us.
Like I'm fixing to go home.
Uh, for the hit the donor second.
Hit the dope or hit the door, meaning leave.
There's also a special form used in the first person, singular I'm, uh.
I'm away right here while you get ready. I'm.
Uh, developed as a contraction of I'm gona. It may be a contraction of I'm gona,
but it's now used slightly differently as a declaration of immediate action.
Whereas I'm gonna, or I'm going is a little further into the future.
Negation, the negative and AAV E is frequently expressed with ain't though.
Not in all contexts with the verb in the simple present tense don't used rather
than ain't, he doesn't live here anymore In the present.
Continuous ain't is used.
Man. Ain't even trying to hear all that.
This is like saying I have no interest in hearing what you're saying.
Notice that ain't often blends in with the words around it.
I ain't is more like I ain't, I ain't even is more like I, and even.
Man, ain't even trying to hear all that.
In the past tense. It's I didn't say anything.
It's also used with the present. Perfect. I haven't said anything.
And he said nothing by the way,
notice that there is a specific difference in the verb tense between ISA and I.
It said those aren't random variations.
You might have also noticed that anymore.
And anything are replaced with their negative counterparts resulting in a double
negative, actually, both of that.
And ain't appear in other dialects of English as well. And aren't unique to Ave,
but it does have a unique kind of double negative,
or sometimes triple negative construction called negative.
Can't nobody sing like she can.
English. This would be, nobody can sing. Like she can't.
Ain't nobody going home til we finish. Nobody's.
Going home until we finish in this construction,
the auxiliary verb moves to the beginning of the sentence and becomes negative
possessives possession in AAV.
He tends to be shown by syntax with the apostrophe S ending deleted.
For example, I was in my dad's house.
Notice that the word dad has no apostrophe S ending,
but it's clear that dad is the one who possesses the house because dad comes
right before house in the sentence for possessive adjectives in the third
person, subject pronouns are.
Used.
Notice that they appears twice one sets the subject. And again,
as the possessor. But again,
we know the second one is possessive because it appears right before the noun
friends ask constructions AAV.
He features several interesting uses of the word.
First it intensifies an adjective.
Who was as some randomized by.
This has been adopted by speakers of other varieties of English, to some extent,
and even some speakers of standard English use it in casual settings when they
want it to be more expressive.
It also reminds me of something Australians and new Zealanders say to intensify,
adjectives. They might say something like this. Beer is cheap as not,
but as the second together with a possessive it's used in place of a
pronoun, but with a sense of urgency,
this means you're going to learn,
but the subtext is that you're chastising or warning someone third.
It can also be used as a reflexive in place.
Self, get your inside the house. Gotcha.
It means get yourself inside the house. Yo replaces yourself.
This is used in other varieties of English as well,
but in a much more limited capacity pronunciation,
African American vernacular English also has a characteristic accent,
or rather a range of accents that share some common features.
We can't talk about all those features here,
but let's look at a few of them are list pronunciation, AAV.
He tends to be our list at the end of words,
similar to the accents of England and some Northeastern American accents.
Brother, mother, sister.
At least in some varieties of AAV E when R appears after O or U the
R disappears.
And the word ends in an O sound door dough floor
becomes, hello, your becomes,
yo sure becomes show some diphthongs,
become Manav thongs. For example, my ride becomes more,
a ride refers to a car by the way, in standard English,
the vowel and my and ride is a diphthong basically meaning that the vowel
shifts from one to another, within a single syllable, uh, I,
I in AAV E it's just one continuous vowel sound. Ah,
also my might be pronounced with a Schwab when it's unstressed in rapid speech,
like ma.
Changes in T.
H sounds. In other words, interdental fricatives thug and the,
the voiceless T H sound Thur is sometimes replaced by FA.
Beth Bev South South. The way these teams.
H sounds are rendered as FA reminds me of some dialects spoken in England,
voiceless sometimes becomes tough or cut.
This sound is a voiceless dental stop,
which is somewhere between a T sound and thumb.
The voiceless T H sound with might become. And in that sample,
you can hear the globalization of the T sound. It often becomes a global stop,
just like tea does in general, American English in certain contexts,
like at the end of a word, voiced, the sometimes becomes de or the,
this is a voice to dental stop.
You could say that it's somewhere between D a D sound and the voice,
the sound that might be.
That some.
Consonants are silent.
This includes the final continent in some continent clusters, for instance,
past is pronounced pairs and hand becomes
to be clear. This happens in other accents as well, including mine,
but it tends to be more consistent in AAV E even in some contexts in which I
would pronounce the sound.
Also initial consonant sounds are sometimes dropped in auxiliary verbs like
don't and quasi auxiliary verbs like Ghana, I don't know,
becomes no. This process probably also resulted in the future form.
I'm up that we saw before some words have different stress,
which can actually undo the vowel reduction of standard English in standard
English. Well, at least in general, American English,
this word is pronounced police in AAV E it's, pronounced police.
Actually, the man in the recording stresses the second syllable,
but it's often stressed on the first syllable.
And as with some other features of AAV E this is also a feature of Southern
speech in general. So that's interesting, right? In my accent,
the O is dropped or at least reduced,
but in AAV E the O is clearly pronounced.
So when sounds are dropped in a dialect like AAV E is that any different from me
dropping certain sounds when I speak the truth is that the phonology of any
spoken variety of English is separate from English spelling.
And every variety has somewhat different phonological rules that it speakers
follow should speakers of AAV E be encouraged to give up their dialect in favor
of standard English. Well,
keep in mind that all over the world in various different languages,
there are dialects that people use in informal situations while they learn the
standard language at school and use that in formal situations,
including writing. There are dialects of German, Japanese, Arabic,
and countless other languages.
And people switch between dialectal speech and standard speech.
Depending on the context,
you can make a good argument that everyone in a society should learn the
standard language well in order to increase their opportunities and to improve
communication between different segments of society.
But there's nothing that makes a dialect incorrect.
If your intention is to speak that dialect,
while speaking a dialect at a job interview might be incorrect. In that context,
speaking it with your friends is not so standard.
English is clearly an important tool, but Ave is not inferior to it.
It's simply different from standard English, just as all dialects are.
That includes the dialects of great Britain, Ireland, Australia,
and everywhere else that English has spoken the question of the day to speakers
of African American vernacular English.
To what extent do you use it in daily life?
And to what extent do you use standard English?
And can you add any features of AAV that didn't appear in the video and to
others?
Are there any words or expressions you use that originally came from Ave?
What are they leave your responses in the comments down below the men who
recorded the audio samples for this video,
Lawrence is an artist who creates fantastic portraits like these,
and he can create custom portraits of you too.
I recommend you follow him on Instagram and check out his work.
I also want to give a big shout out to all the Lang focus, Patrion supporters,
especially the top tier patrons whose names are on the screen. Check out
patrion.com/lang focus and check out the benefits of the various tiers and to
everyone. Thank you for watching and have a nice.
Yay.